je suis très touchée par voire de devoir
c'est ces femmes c'est actrice très
connue qui décide de se mettre à nu de
se donner la main pour former une chaîne
de solidarité afin de passer un message
clair net et précis
je salue leur courage parce que ça prend
énormément de courage qui sépare facile
mais sauf que l'oeil sont une gagne qui
soutiennent nathalie simard s'est très
bien ce que ça veut dire osé tenir tête
aux plus puissants de l'industrie
artistique
il faut du cran il faut de la force elle
l'a fait seul malgré la peur et le
chantage c'est la peur puis maman car tu
sais moi je me suis fait menacé par mon
agresseur si tu parles tu auras plus
rien de rare que tu va briser la
carrière de tout le monde
toi ta famille je m'en occuperai [ __ ]
elle a été en quelque sorte une
pionnière quand elle a dénoncé son
gérant guy cloutier en 2004 il n'y avait
pas de twitter et de mots clics pas de
vague de solidarité non plus l'appui au
sein même de l'industrie a été timide et
les contrats on veut disparu vous êtes
en oui beaucoup
j'ai vraiment comme ressenti que dans le
côté sombre de ce milieu particulier
qu'il ya un hic se sont donné la main
pour me démolir ou me définir comme une
femme que je n'étais pas c'est ce qui
m'attriste le plus de voir jusqu'à quel
point on peut se rallier du côté du
criminel et comment la victime laissés
pour compte et que c'est la victime ou
la survivante parce que moi je peux une
victime aujourd'hui je suis une
survivante etc c'est moi qui mangent les
coûts qui lui me fait comme tant
d'autres elle se demande si la
mobilisation planétaire à laquelle on
assiste sera éphémère ou s'il s'agit
d'un véritable point tournant encore
aujourd'hui des femmes partagent leur
histoire d'agression et de harcèlement
l'actrice reese witherspoon a dévoilé
qu'elle aussi a été agréé
c'est par un directeur alors qu'elle
n'avait que 16 ans elle dit qu'elle a
honte d'avoir gardé le silence qu'elle
en veut à mort aux agents qui nous ont
conseillé de se taire pour protéger sa
carrière sauf que moment donné faut se
lever debout
faites le au moins pour vos enfants faut
le faire pour justement avoir une
nouvelle génération cern d'esprit est
forte parce que sa prise une fille
solide mieux imprimer un homme un homme
c'est l'injustice
il ya tellement d'injustices même si le
plaider coupable s'est défini comme un
monstre ya encore de la justice qui suit
ça ça fait mal quand vous voyez le
milieu artistique aujourd'hui s'insurge
et de ce que ce qu'on dénonce à un
niveau des désirs faut dénoncer ce
qu'ils font pareil au québec parce qu'il
ya une hypocrisie
c'est à eux de le dire je peux pas me
prononcer là dessus moi j'ose espérer et
j'ose croire que s'est tenu un éveil
j'avais toujours en éveil l'éveil des
consciences alors ce qu'il faut faire
c'est ce qu'il a fallu faire il ya 13
ans de sopi c'est quand vous avez
dénoncé
ouais très peu d'amertume non oh non
j'ai pas par force au moins alors je me
suis libérée et aujourd'hui à la veille
de ses 50 ans nathalie simard dit
qu'elle n'a aucun regret et voulant dire
quoi aux femmes qui se mange à vous la
peine de dénoncer leur dis oui ça vaudra
toujours la plaine il lui aura fallu des
années pour se guérir alors commencé à
donner des spectacles el jarrah temps
plein sa cabane à sucre avec son
conjoint est ce qu'il est mais
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas tant de voir un
géant comme wayne ce qu'il tombait ce
qui la touche c'est d'entendre des
milliers de femmes briser leur sillage
c'est la cause je l' ai vécu je lai en
moi que je veux mourir avec faîtes moi
mon but quand je dénonçais c'est je veux
faire quelque chose de beau avec ça si
je peux aider
éveiller les consciences mais je vais
avoir fait quelque chose de grand dans
ma vie de mon vivant
on va refaire quelque chose de grand ici
à ma fille et c'est pour moi c'est ce
qui est plus important
une fille à la fois une feuille à la
fois merci mais non merci